when i was growing up
i believed i did not have a voice i
believed a voice
is something that is given to you
but i think we all know now that a voice
is not the challenge having a voice is
not a challenge we all have a physical
voice
the challenge is when we speak
who is listening how are they listening
we have a huge
challenge of connection
soon there will be 10 billion voices on
earth
and how do we guarantee communicative
intelligence how do we keep listening
to one another
and i believe we have to make knowledge
experiential we have to take the
greatest ideas of humanity today
and make it so that we can touch feel
taste and smell them
if we do that we can reach
the unreachable
we can push these concepts into
conversation
and conversation is the glue of all
things
as an artist i
express and experiment with the human
voice and for the past six months i've
been collecting some of the most
precious and vulnerable and
extraordinary vocal expressions and
using them to generate
voice gems
digital precious objects
the aim is for it to become one of the
largest vocal archives on the planet but
to celebrate
voice
the piece you're about to see is a
collection of many techniques from the
past present and possible future of
vocal expression and when you listen
i want you to think about going beyond
your comfort zone of voice to be
encouraged to speak up because i believe
all of our voices
can do more
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
can you hear me
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
ah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
can you hear me
can you hear me
can you hear me
can you hear me now
can you hear me
can you hear me
can you hear me
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey
[Music]
wow
[Music]
you hear me
now
[Applause]